gegangen im auswärtigen amt am 8 april
2016 hat die republik türkei ein straff
verlangen hinsichtlich des moderators
jan böhmermann wegen dessen sendungs
abschnitts über präsident erdogan
gestellt gesetzliche voraussetzung für
die strafverfolgung des speziellen
delikts der beleidigung von organen und
vertretern ausländischer staaten ist
eine ermächtigung der bundesregierung
die bundesregierung hat dieses ersuchen
entsprechend der staatspraxis geprüft an
dieser prüfung waren das auswärtige amt
das bundesjustizministerium das
bundesinnenministerium und das
bundeskanzleramt beteiligt es gab
unterschiedliche auffassungen zwischen
den koalitionspartnern union und spd
im ergebnis wird die bundesregierung im
vorliegenden fall die ermächtigung
erteilen
ich möchte dazu gerne näher stellung
nehmen die türkei ist ein land mit dem
deutschland eng und freundschaftlich
verbunden ist
über die vielen menschen mit türkischen
wurzeln hier im land über enge
wirtschaftliche verflechtung und unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung als alliierte
in der nordatlantischen allianz die
türkei führt verhandlungen für einen
beitritt zur europäischen union in
dieser engen partnerschaft sind
gegenseitige auch völkerrechtlich
geschuldete achtung ebenso wie der
offene austausch zu den entwicklungen
des rechtsstaats der unabhängigkeit der
gerichte und des meinungspluralismus von
besonderer bedeutung
umso mehr erfüllen uns die lage der
medien in der türkei und das schicksal
einzelner journalisten mit großer sorge
wie auch einschränkungen des
demonstrationsrechts
die bundesregierung wird auch in zukunft
auf allen ebenen die postulate von
rechtsstaatlichkeit gewaltenteilung und
pluralismus gegenüber der türkei
anmahnen
wir treten dafür ein dass bei unseren
partnern und verbündeten die freiheit
der meinung und die unabhängigkeit der
justiz in gleichem umfang gewährleistet
sein müssen wie in europa
und anderen ländern der demokratischen
welt
wir setzen uns gegenüber anderen staaten
dafür ein grundrechte wie die
meinungsfreiheit die kunstfreiheit und
die pressefreiheit zu achten
wir fordern ihre achtung und ihren
schutz auch von der türkei ein
wir fordern das weil wir von der stärke
des rechtsstaats überzeugt sind im
rechtsstaat sind grundrechte wie die
meinungsfreiheit die kunstfreiheit und
die pressefreiheit elementar sie sind
elementar für pluralismus und demokratie
im rechtsstaat ist die justiz unabhängig
in ihm ist garantiert dass die
verfahrensrechte des betroffenen gewahrt
werden
in ihm gilt die unschuldsvermutung
im rechtsstaat ist es nicht sache der
regierung sondern von
staatsanwaltschaften und gerichten die
persönlich das persönlichkeitsrecht und
andere belange gegen die presse und
kunstfreiheit abzuwägen
in ihm bedeutet die erteilung einer
ermächtigung zur strafverfolgung des
speziellen delikts der beleidigung von
organen und vertretern ausländischer
staaten weder eine vorverurteilung des
betroffenen noch eine vorgreifen der
entscheidung über grenzen der kunst
presse und meinungsfreiheit sondern
lediglich dass die rechtliche prüfung
der unabhängigen justiz über antwortet
wird und nicht die regierung sondern
staatsanwaltschaften und gerichte das
letzte wort haben werden
genau in diesem und in keinem anderen
verständnis und genau in diesem und in
keinem anderen gesamt fragen wird die
bundesregierung im vorliegenden
konkreten fall hinsichtlich des
moderators jan böhmermann die von mir
eingangs vorgetragene ermächtigung
erteilen
darüber hinaus möchte ich ihnen
mitteilen dass unabhängig von diesen
konkreten verfahren die bundesregierung
der auffassung ist dass § 103
strafgesetzbuch
als strafnorm zum schutz der
persönlichen ehre für die zukunft
entbehrlich ist
wir werden deshalb einen gesetzentwurf
zu seiner aufhebung vorlegen der
gesetzentwurf soll noch in dieser
wahlperiode verabschiedet werden und
2018 in kraft treten
vielen dank